[Music]
in big [ __ ] news submitted by American
noodles what the [ __ ] is that
Robin pasta is Italian no it's a cup of
noodles like bracing myself for this one
chicken noodle soup oh no a girl had her
thumb amputated and replaced with her
toe maybe she's really cute toes I'm
gonna say like how these things look I
think I already have those magical
thumbs you do have to holy [ __ ] I'm
sorry and her toes look like humans yeah
yeah I got those actually you were in
the God was in the character creator on
you and he put all the points everywhere
else put your hands like you you don't
have good-looking hands I don't yeah
yeah you get you got all the you put all
the points of Regina says that God's
fair because see yeah I'll take it
it's okay my only fault it's I don't
mind it I like terrible Florida table
floor have Jill's a [ __ ] just right
here she goes wait a minute every time
we say [ __ ] even while she can't
breathe she's like just to cover it's
not like say the N word do all midgets
let's be real do all of them agree they
should be called little people follow
them together and get all the smallest
podium so that they can have like a
little discussion group oh we should get
like a little ballot box one I think
they can vote on with little pens and
stuff it's hard not to make fun of
anomalies mm-hmm but let's keep going
that's it's not about that today this
the teenager here the 17 year old from
Australia she was on her way to become a
professional cricket player so she was
on a trip to Hong Kong she was playing
cricket and that's when she had suffered
a fracture but like she injured her
thumb but she didn't realize it was a
fracture until she got home and she went
to the doctor and that's something told
her that she has a fractured thumb and
so don't they just usually just put a
[ __ ] popsicle stick right there and
then right yeah then she was supposed to
go she went to go see her local
orthopedic surgeon she was gonna have an
operation to fix the fracture but they
put on a tourniquet to not like to
restrict the buck blood flow during the
surgery died and then they try it
someone wrote in her chart that the
tourniquet was removed after this
operation but it was not oh no so she
didn't realize yeah she um realize until
how long was it thing and I forgot was
it five days thank you so it's been in
there five days no blood flying days no
blood flow after her surgery oh hey guys
they ended up having to amputate it you
know why it gets infected no it just
dies right it died
runs out of blood yeah well I like the
way you said it with all the confidence
yeah like he like he came up on some
extra news yeah so they're saying that
after that they took her big toe removed
it did to her hand to make a new thumb
she wanted yeah you tell her it did did
they consult oh my god magic [ __ ] up
again no or just imagine they were just
like all [ __ ] we gotta cover this up
what we do oh [ __ ] but to me it would be
close right like yeah I'm [ __ ] we
couldn't just get a thumb implant so
that's the thing that's that is the
thumb replacement but what a bummer
let's just say okay to it well I didn't
get to finish so now they're creating a
replacement toe using her hip bone Wow
just keep the [ __ ] toe on the foot
what a bit alone and then just get the
hip bone for the foot well then what she
wouldn't watch me what are you gonna do
to make it replace the hip bone
forehead forehead bone and put the hip
bone to take her eyebrow they're missing
one piece of this puzzle they're just
taking other people just smashing she's
gonna be so [ __ ] and we just we took her
titty and we bility of yeah she couldn't
have got a thumb from somewhere else
like or another body part that's [ __ ]
crazy okay sorry
absolutely at this point has nothing to
do with the doctor I feel like since
she's Australian she's tough so should
even give a [ __ ] I don't care about my
body part well she's probably watching
right now she's got one eye patch she's
like that pretty funny that the book I
use the eye for their head that's a hip
replacement yeah they put it in the
middle of her hand yeah [ __ ] Pan's
Labyrinth did [ __ ] dude dude why not
they keep bugging her up what's next man
so we get to see the doctor to Brittany
wait is it grab can you warn us me look
like a [ __ ] angler fish and [ __ ] I
want to niche I don't know what it means
it's always lowlife nature that's a
flattering picture you guys gonna get a
better picture that's mean that's like
Australian sounds look like he knows
what he's doing though we're playing
cricket now warning I've never seen a
game of give me this [ __ ] is what you
guys seen a game of cricket ready
laughing after leaving the tourniquet on
it must have smelled oh and by the way I
forgot to mention the reason why she
didn't know that this is a toe that's
really good it sits on the joint great
one I think you can see this one you
can't even tell
Gio she has a hotter hand than yeah
she's a [ __ ] toe hand to you I hope
so [ __ ] that she still looks good that
looks really worried about is how it's
gonna affect her cricket career yeah go
to the doctor with that [ __ ] black
nub coming out and be like so doc what
do you think that's the thing I was
gonna say so the reason why she didn't
know about the tourniquet being left on
is because they put a cast over like
something to cover it like a bandage I
smell it through the screen that's just
ank like so yeah that's what you should
totally see the [ __ ] out of these
doctors holy [ __ ] that's when you when
you're okay to sue yeah ruin the show
these people holy [ __ ] dude do you guys
would you guys rather keep like let's
yet to choose would you rather keep your
thumb or your big toe
I don't know cuz like your big top plays
a lot into your athletic ability
no even just balance your ability to
move and have footwork and run and move
sideways like your thumb or your big toe
control so much try to use your thumb
without your thumb good luck you'll
never do it I feel like I get a
prosthetic toe like I feel like that
might be easier to work with
I just saw can these stuff that part of
the shoe you can hide these things yeah
can't wear sandals no more though I saw
a count with a wooden hand once and
you're like a like a like a it's like a
wooden hand is like oh [ __ ] did he have
an eyepatch - not a parrot I wish
mightily instead I just left him his
hand oh alright and then you saw him
you're like oh you're a nice guy
those are left thumb right buddy I can
live without my left yeah so I can't cuz
I kept I were to play baseball or hockey
like I need my right thumb this one I
just what about cricket I've never
played it's like the paddle it's like a
paddle batting sport so this one I just
need to grip the top part but I need the
bottom thumbs I'm surprised she couldn't
get a dump transplant by a dead person a
lot of people died Jody has it that
thumb huh
Judy had the dead thumb so she gets
another transplant another dead thumb
dude I can't wait till we can grow those
grow all the [ __ ] can grow in a lab yeah
yeah like how pigs have ears growing on
them Association [ __ ] rats Chinese
got a head in here growing on his
forehead nose cuz he something happened
to his nose or some [ __ ] who's going to
own his forehead maybe she needed to be
you can't sleep on it your smoke that's
really good cuz you know know so I
forgot to mention so you know how it was
the tourniquet was on part of her finger
yeah so they had to amputate that black
part but then the rest of the part they
took it out or like they removed it and
stitch it to her groin for six weeks to
get the nerves and arteries working
again but she had a [ __ ] toe just
dangling from her [ __ ] yeah like just
dangle one girl leave her alone already
[ __ ] doctors got the same doctor you
know that Rob Schneider movie were like
he got hit by a car or something he got
all these animal parts at the same dock
the animal
yeah classroom right up there with space
on a speech right down there with yeah
exactly
yes oh no like I said her family's
looking into legal [ __ ] yeah dude at
what point is like the doctor like come
in and you're just like what the [ __ ]
now oh yeah what else do you have to do
to me now I like go in your scenario
they keep going back to the same doctor
though well I I imagine she never left
the [ __ ] hospital I imagine she's
just there they seriously you know
wonder like that mechanic comes back
because your cousin is like hey we found
another beam that one person that
actually wrote down an attorney yeah you
[ __ ] fired why this garage her
phone's caught on yeah extinct your
thumb exchange yeah
oh [ __ ] I actually feel bad for that
person kinda a little bit but also think
about it it's your mistake though yeah
but then you [ __ ] you know but you also
don't have to live with [ __ ] oh we
live really normal lives okay in the
room up in how dope is it that the
stress of our lives will never reach
that [ __ ] we're like you're done you
[ __ ] up my work like okay first case we
lose a video right yeah we lose a side
of video you have to use our [ __ ]
faces or whatever yeah but this [ __ ] is
like at both of these babies but what if
we go to Australian hospital what
happens to us just don't go faster as
well I'm not going on Australia's [ __ ]
scariest [ __ ] we got mosquitoes bigger
than your house uh-huh what part of
Australia you talking they got dragons
they're all kind of [ __ ] I've been there
they have spiders big in your head no
that's it probably the outback yeah like
is that not in Australia they have house
spiders that like can [ __ ] take your
cat up in the ceiling [ __ ] have you seen
the ones that like burst open with a
bunch of bees that go everywhere [ __ ]
that yeah just in Australia though whoa
I'm sorry maybe the Amazon rainforest
geo
at least you know I like the Amazon
rainforest is it in your closet or your
attic it could be no it couldn't be
that's ridiculous
[Music]